hey guys Jena and Dave we are back at
Roseanne's kitchen table why are we here
find out right there just click right
there and it will take you to it you
will find out everything you need to
know and we have one more for you this
week I saw an interesting article in
HuffPo from something on Psychology
Today about the 7 Habits of unhappy
people I wanted to talk about it because
I know you to be a happy woman Dina and
I wanted to judge you and see if you
have any of these traits so number one
number one
your default belief that life is hard
this missus kind of interesting because
there are a lot of people you meet all
that yeah that are just in that thing
they think that's a word thank you that
is a word they think life is there to
defeat them and it is coming at them all
the time i life is hard life is like a
chat you're like uphill all the time and
sometimes it gets a little easier the
incline gets fast and then suddenly life
is hard
ya know if you want to attach all of
your problems to it and all the reasons
why you haven't been successful and all
the reason why you're not in this
relation of that rather then that's your
business but like yeah life is hard
yeah now you grab your little tool belt
stop bitching and fix it you ever have
those brief moments like a run maybe of
like a week or even two weeks sometimes
you'll get it maybe for a month I don't
know a lot where are you Sept 2012 yeah
what it was hard rough year Oh rough I
was going to go where you suddenly have
a run where you're like wow I have this
thing yeah like it's working but that
usually doesn't last that long because
that's not the nature of the beast or
well and that's a thing I think any
momentum begets momentum so if you're
like life is hard
life is hard oh my god gravity is so
much heavier around me than everybody
else and it really does become that and
if you can lift yourself out of it god
bless you yeah what's the second one
Gina oh so you believe most people can't
be trusted I know a lot of ladies yeah
guys are constantly undermining each
other to destroy each other right well
yeah I was actually thinking more in
terms of like they go out on dates they
meet dudes on tinder and you're
surprised that you can't trust them
right you're saying don't trust their
not it was relatively anonymous people
that you meet online is that do we have
another four or five minutes
okay and that's the thing it's like I
don't think most people aren't
trustworthy but I think you definitely
choose your own adventure and if you're
swiping right all the time then you're
gonna meet some cuckoos yeah and
especially for us I mean we are in Los
Angeles and believe it or not people not
everyone you meet in this town is
trustworthy but they will smile at you
while they're trying to kill you
absolutely
the third one you concentrate on what's
wrong in this world versus what's right
a lot of people do this a lot I try
really try not to do this like this is
my run like I get up and I try to like
get something good going is it what's
wrong in the world or what's wrong in
your life I guess it's probably both
yeah like you can focus on all the
things that you don't have and
everything that's system screwing you
versus just get out there and kind of
yeah think well you know in the words of
Dolly Parton in one of her newer songs
I'm a big fan and shut up by the way
because I already know I'm not ready on
the joke but yeah she does song called
better get to live in and you know what
like I because I was doing the shower
this morning but that's the thing it's
like well there's a this is the same as
believing life is hard there are things
out there that are going to be obstacles
now you want to stand there and stare at
it and cry or you want to try and figure
out how to fix it yeah and not to be too
spiritual but it's a little bit of the
secret like law of attraction right you
think things are gonna be bad and then
you bring this show up do you what do
you got next you know oh
you compare yourself to others and
harbour jealousy yeah and that we always
said that's comparing your insides to
somebody else's outsides yeah which is I
mean it's so tempting all the time so I
my best example of this is in 1999 I was
an intern at the Daily Show before it
was like a huge hit John had just taken
over from Craig Kilborn and I tried to
get a job there they told me I was gonna
get a job but then it fell through
literally the day I was supposed to
start and then a couple years went by I
was doing stand-up struggling stand-up
comic you're hungry literally don't have
a lot of money living in a shitty
apartment blah blah blah and then a guy
who was a PA when I was an intern so the
PA is the lowest paid job you can
basically have on a TV show he then I
was watching the Emmys one night and
John because they had already accepted
so many enemies and enemies that was so
no paging dr. Froese yeah John
John had accepted so many Emmys already
that he didn't show up to the Emmys and
the guy that I was friends with at the
time was now the executive producer of
The Daily Show and he accepted the Emmys
and I was really struggling as a comic
at that time and I remember thinking
sitting there like did my life get too
real yeah I was jealous of him I was
angry at him and then I only knew him to
be a good guy so then I was like I can't
focus on that kind of energy yeah
and that we're friends now and he's
still off doing pretty good stuff but
yeah you can't hold that stuff and
that's not even the life path that you
were supposed to take anyway yeah you
just saw success and you wanted it yeah
exactly all right what else are you
consider your future with worry and fear
people get caught up in this one a lot
like worrying about [ __ ] that hasn't
even happened yeah I can tell you
personally in therapy it's called offal
izing I'm pretty sure your your
therapist made up that phrase awful yeah
yeah because we we all do it we awful
eyes we're Chicken Little the sky is
falling and we get in this habit where
we were thinking something good is gonna
happen to me oh that means something
terrible has to happen to make the world
balance that's not true
ah all right well the final one as two
people that talk for a living do you
know what is it oh you feel your
conversations with gossip and complaints
well you know look when we talk politics
it seems like complaining a lot and I
think people sometimes people are
commenting like you hate America you
know because I want the system to know I
love America yeah I want it to work
better yeah so what comes off as I
suppose complaining about the system
doesn't work right our politicians are
sold out all that stuff to me it's like
this is as I believe in it we got to
make it better we can't just let it go
to Helena and then in the microcosmic
version they say that you know bonding
gossiping about people creates bonding
between the two people who are hating on
that other chick so hello so gossiping
is like the strongest thing you can do
to build a formative relation exactly
and that's not that's not a judgment
that's just a fact from something I have
found on Twitter so that's better
so that's the thing I mean it has its
place it strengthens that core
relationship but at what price
there you know do you guys buy into
these these seven factoids on what will
make you depressed and screw up your
life let us know in the comment section
right down below
bribe all that good stuff and we're
gonna do this again next week Barney
well it's the holidays we'll see
whatever weekend they shut the camera
we'll start talking that [ __ ]